now this pandemic has caused a lot of
people to think about their financial
futures
especially when it comes to saving and
retiring
and really can anyone even retire in
this
economy and today on your money story we
have
amman and christina browning of our rich
journey
they saved two million dollars in eight
years while working government jobs and
side kids
they became financially independent last
year and they retired
at the age of 41 and 39.
guys welcome to the show and thank you
so much for joining us
oh thank you for having us we are
excited to be here and
share our story maybe inspire some other
folks to retire early
yeah thank you so much fernie we're so
excited to talk to you
great great well let's get right into it
you two did not come from money
yet you were able to retire pretty young
how did you do it
and how does it feel yeah i i love that
we get to start
with that question because i think it's
so important to inform people that
you don't need to come from money in
order to
understand and start to begin to learn
financial literacy
and to retire early so i mean if you're
talking about
financial independence and you're
talking about retiring early there's
really
three pillars in terms of how you
support that
journey throughout your whole journey
and then retiring early and it's about
saving more money it's about making more
money
and it's about investing that money and
so
that's what we really focused on
throughout our entire journey
on those three things at the same time
continuously working on those things
and improving those things so that by
the end of our journey after eight years
we had amassed enough money
in order to retire early and to your
question about how it feels
it feels good because when we were
when we were on this journey and and it
it you know it seemed like we were able
to do this in a relatively short amount
of time
but when we were in the midst of it it
was a lot of work so to finally be here
to to be in a place that we've
visualized for years and years and years
it is
it feels really good to have achieved
our goal
it must feel good i mean uh to still
have your whole life ahead of you
um but i gotta push back there a lot of
people feel like this is too good to be
true
do you think people can really do this
right now with the economy that we're
facing
yes yeah i mean to me we talk about
the whole journey about retiring early
in about even how much you need to
retire early right
and it's all relative some people may
say i can't
i can't amass millions and millions of
dollars to retire
but it's actually relative i mean we're
a family of four
it depends on your location it depends
on your expenses
and so i think you know we talk about
those three pillars about saving more
making more and
investing more on the road to financial
independence but
one thing that ties all those things
together
is your mentality so if you go into
something and i think this is general
in life if you go into something with
this negative attitude
that you cannot achieve it or that it
can't be done
then it's very likely that you will not
achieve it and
it won't be done for you but if you go
into
this journey or anything else that you
do with this
mindset that you can do this and that
everything that you do you're looking
towards ways that you can save more
money
that you can look for these high side
hustles to make more money and you're
learning about investing and investing
that money
that's really what it takes in order to
achieve financial independence i think
financial independence is really for
anyone but you have to start off with
that proper mentality that
you can achieve that early retirement
and that financial independence
level so how were how what were some of
the ways that you guys
used i saw on your youtube channel
several different ways that you
made money saved money and you invested
run us through how you did each of them
a few ways
well it definitely took a combination of
things i mean
there was no one single thing that got
us to financial independence
but what we started with was a plan and
the first thing we did
was identify what our fire number was
how much money we needed to retire
and then with that number we had
something that we could
be intentional about working towards and
so
it was just a matter of backing our way
into that number
and so we looked at our biggest expenses
first we looked on the savings side
first
and we looked at ways we could save
money so we did things like we house
hacked
we lived uh in our home we did something
called a live and flip
we um we downsized significantly
and we did you know we stopped trying to
keep up with the joneses we were driving
uh a x5 bmw we were living beyond our
means
and we just started to look at different
ways that we could save big ticket items
and then we worked our way down to the
little ticket items
and now as far as making more money when
you're on this journey
you realize that there's actually money
in the streets
right so when when you have a number
that you're working towards
you can identify things to to meet those
goals
so we were doing things like retail
arbitrage we were doing things like
one day we were driving along and we saw
a garbage bin full of these wine crates
this
this this this wine manufacturer was
throwing away all of these wine crates
and we said
that's art so we can we can make
something out of those crates and resell
those things
so there you have it we were reselling
those i mean create christina created an
etsy store where she was writing tooth
fairy letters
to people that were you know buying them
around the world
so you have to be creative and from
saving my
money and then making more money we were
able to take
that gap and invest that into real
estate or into the stock market
and if you're if you have a plan and
you're working towards it
as intentional as we were you can you
can you can reach
those types of goals you can reach
financial independence and i'll also add
i mean there's one other thing that i
wanted to add to was that
we were very creative in terms of
creating money from nothing so oman gave
the
the example of the wine crates but we
also went through this phase where we
were creating
furniture and we were reselling the
furniture and we were making them
from pallets you know the pallets that
you get from the grocery store you can
get those for free
we started tearing them up using the
wood for that and building furniture and
selling that on facebook and
and craigslist and it's like it's like i
said when you're going through this
process
you start finding ways like hey i can
get money this way i can make money this
way
and even if you don't have any money at
all it's sort of figuring out ways to
start
generating money from scratch okay
and we have a question from the audience
actually uh
is retirement an important goal
and what do you use for your income now
yes yes so i think there's there's two
things that
well there's the fire movement which is
financial independence retire early
and so i don't think retiring early has
to be for everyone
i think it doesn't have to be an
important goal but i do think that
financial independence
should be an important goal for everyone
so that retire early
is just an added on aspect to it because
if you reach financial independence it
means that you have an you have amassed
enough money to live on for the rest of
your life so
if you wanted to retire you could but if
you don't you enjoy your work you enjoy
doing what you do
you can continue doing that and i think
it gives people
so much more freedom to pursue what they
want to do
if they love and enjoy their work
there's just less stress involved with
it when you have financial independence
so i would say retiring early may not
necessarily need to be a goal for
everyone but i think that financial
independence
should be a goal for everyone and in
terms of income it's tied to
your financial independence number so we
started off
investing in real estate and the stock
market we were flipping real estate and
we sold our prop we sold our property
took the profits and put it into our
stock portfolio
and so now once you reach financial
independence you have a stock portfolio
that you live off of and that generates
the income for for you
and it's called the four percent rule
and it's basically taking four percent
from your stock portfolio and that you
that you use
that to pay for all of your expenses and
so it's
tied into that financial independence
number
that you would need to achieve in order
to reach financial independence or also
add on that
extra component of retiring early okay
thank you for explaining
fire that was definitely a question i
wanted to make clear from everyone
and it sounds like what you've done is
really by
time so you have all this time now
and how are you spending your retirement
and do you get bored
oh no we are spending our retirement
however we want to and that
you know when we were working there were
so many things that we wanted to do
but we had 40 hours a week that we had
to give to someone else
now that we've taken those 40 hours back
we can do whatever we want with them
and so christina and i we are very
active we're outdoor people
in fact we just bought a house in the
country here in portugal
and we've been spending a lot of time
renovating our house we plan on putting
this entire
farm in our in our backyard and trying
to live a little bit more
sustainable but we do things like that
we spend time with our children
we travel and of course we make our
youtube videos once a week we just have
fun talking to people about financial
independence on youtube
and you know we're still parents that's
what's really cool about
being early retirees with children is
that we get to be
involved and engaged in our children's
lives and we don't have
this gnawing feeling of work on us or
something else pulling us away from the
attention that we can
give our children our family our friends
and i think that goes back to what you
were saying renita
about should retirement be a goal for
everyone
and you have to think about what would
your retirement life look like
once you retire if you can't envision
that then
you may get bored in retirement and
maybe
that retirement component isn't
something that you should strive for it
should just be the financial
independence component
but if you see yourself working towards
something you're working towards a life
that you envision
in retirement that you're enjoying that
you're staying active that you have so
many things that you want to do
but you can't do them because you're
working then maybe that early retirement
aspect
added on to financial independence is
what you should be is what your goals
should be
okay so were you guys always this good
with money
i love that question because no you know
when we when we were growing up
we we had you know very completely
different families of course like
different
different concepts about how to raise
kids but
between the both of us our parents did
not talk to us about money
we didn't come from families with money
we weren't raised to understand i didn't
even
know what the stock market was when i
was growing up and our kids now we have
a 12 and 14 year old they are very well
versed in the stock market
but growing up we didn't have that
background we didn't
understand how to invest money and so
for us
it was a process of learning of becoming
financially literate
and understanding how to invest in the
stock market and not
getting thrown by these get rich quick
schemes and really understanding what is
an
index fund how is that different from an
actively managed mutual fund what's a
reit
you know all of these types of things we
really taught ourselves so that we could
be
savvy investors and so that we could
grow our portfolios
yeah and and to take that a step further
you know whenever we
learned something we would we would put
it into action
i mean the first time we invested in
real estate
we had read a book about lease options
and we thought
this is the best strategy for us to get
started in real estate
is to go into a lease option and this
was way back when we at first
like we we had graduated from college
and we we couldn't afford to get a place
of our own
but we figured out another way to get
invested in real estate
so for us we're always about taking
action you can only learn so much
but you need to take that next step and
that's what we're always telling people
you you've watched enough of our youtube
videos you know
what to do and i think most people do
they're capable
of taking those steps it's just things
hold them back you know they have
limiting beliefs
they you know they have people in their
lives that aren't
supporting their goals and the thing
about me and christina is that
when we have an idea and we bring it to
one another
we get to yes we you know when we first
thought about financial independence and
we brought up this crazy idea
christina was like how can we do it okay
let's put together this plan
and we just we just got work doing it so
it sounds like you guys haven't
had
but i had to jump in because you
seem as if you are talking about the
importance of having
a mate uh on the same page
when it comes to your financial literacy
well that's powerful
yeah yeah i mean it
it definitely helps the journey that's i
mean there are definitely people
in situations where one is a big saver
and one is a big spender
and you have to in that situation it's
like you have to find a way to come to
the middle
you're not going to convince the other
person to become this
saver just like you overnight or the
saver isn't going to become a spender
overnight sometimes you have to work
towards the middle
and then start to really refine how you
look at money that way
but being on the same page as your
spouse is
definitely definitely a huge hurdle that
if you're already there you don't have
to overcome that hurdle
and it's also you know being on the same
page as your spouse but then
also being entirely supportive and i
think
that is something between us that we
really focus on
when we have this harebrained idea of
hey i want to retire before i'm 40.
when amman came to me and said that you
know it's very i could have very easily
said
that's insane we've never heard of
anyone retiring before 40
why would we ever be able to do
something like that but as a couple
we're very supportive of each other and
thinking rather than the first answer
being
no we're not going to do that it's okay
yes we could do that
let's figure out how to do that and and
you know
if you're if you're not in a
relationship if you if you're going at
this alone
you want to surround yourself with
people that are that are going to be
supportive
so your friends and family i think that
you know this is something that you have
to be able to consistently do
for a long period of time and if you
have people that are
in your ear on your shoulder you know
just throwing hate on your journey
it's going to stifle you and so if
you're in a relationship
or if you're doing this solo you need to
surround yourself with positive
people so something else that's
interesting about you guys is
the whole house is involved your
daughters have their own our rich
journey junior
so how can parents get their kids
involved in becoming
financially independent for the whole
house
oh my goodness that's a that's a great
question because our
our daughters we try to teach them about
money
in a in in a very unique way so we
we we associate time with money
and i'll tell you i'll tell you a very
quick story one day we had gone to pick
our daughters up
from daycare and i think they were like
five or
maybe four or five years old and they
were talking about their teacher had
this brand new um iphone and
and i said how many hours do you think
she had to work for that iphone how many
how many hours do you think
it took and we sat down they were real
little and we did this calculation
and it was like a week and a half of
working
that she would have to work for this
iphone and we've always gone back to
that lesson when
you're when you're buying something when
you're when you're when you are putting
your money out
you are exchanging your time for that so
that's kind of the foundation that we
started with our children
value money because they understand what
you what you have to do in exchange for
it you have to give
up something for it and it's your
freedom in in most cases right
so if you can take control of your money
you can take control of your freedom
and that's something that we really try
to instill in our kids and their channel
is so amazing because they have their
own style about
talking about money you know we're old
fogies we talk about it a certain way
but they're able to just have fun with
it
yeah and i would say you know one of the
things when as a parent
when you're thinking about how do you
instill these
money skills or these money life lessons
with your children
the first thing is really to understand
that what you do
your children are watching your children
are understanding your relationship with
money
by everything that you do so that's one
thing to keep in mind but
another thing to keep in mind is that
you shouldn't treat
the topic of money as if it's taboo you
know it should be
just an open conversation and you should
just talk about it naturally
it doesn't necessarily mean every day
you sit down your child and you say
okay we spent this this and this you
need to know this and just talk about it
organically and as you do that more and
more your children will ask
more questions they'll learn more we
started a custodial account
for both of our girls and they
understand what they're investing in
they
understand how the market works our
youngest daughter just wrote a
report they had free time in their class
and their teacher
her science teacher was asking her about
investing money so
our youngest daughter wrote a report on
our free time about what market timing
is
what the stock market is what index
funds are and it's
just it's really incredible because they
really absorb things so i would tell
parents
don't underestimate what your children
can learn they are
very open to understanding about money
if you begin to
if you begin to share those topics with
them
okay all right i'll tuck that in my back
pocket
well i want to switch gears here um
you guys just moved to portugal and
lived
in a few different places uh you lived
in your native of california the bay
area you lived in japan
you lived in spain but why did you move
to portugal
oh my goodness there are there are so
many things that are just
amazing about portugal we talked so much
about portugal people have joked and
said that
they should give us an award because so
many people are moving here after
after kind of discovering it but there
are there are just so many benefits to
being here
you know the culture is amazing they're
very welcoming
um in fact portugal has been rated i
think
in the top three countries that are the
most welcoming of foreigners
uh the health care is amazing the cost
of living is amazing i mean
they're just there are just so many
things and and we had the the choice of
retiring
anywhere in the world and we're so glad
that we came to portugal
because we have really had an
opportunity to just
i think really savor retirement the
lifestyle that we have here
it allows us to sip our coffee slowly
to really cherish every moment
and i couldn't think of a better place
to to move to or to retire to
it's amazing here is it also a cheaper
cost of living
it is almost definitely because we're
from the
bay area so i would say for people that
are are watching this
if they're if they're trying to think of
you know maybe i should live to a lower
cost of living or maybe
portugal is a great place if you're
looking to to have
great tax exemptions right great tax
incentives but i would say
if your goal is that retire early
component
we had several different places we're
from oakland the san francisco bay area
which has a very very high cost of
living
we also considered thailand because we
had traveled a lot to thailand
amman studied abroad in college of
thailand we thought of spain because we
lived there also
but i think if you're thinking about
where do you ultimately want to retire
you need to tie that
to your financial independence
retirement early number that fire number
the amount
of money that you need to retire and and
we would really recommend that you
focus your number on that higher cost of
living so that's what we did we focused
on
amassing enough to live in the san
francisco bay area because our idea was
if we move to portugal and if we don't
like it after a while or if we don't
like it right away or for whatever
reason we want to move back to the
states
we didn't want to get pigeonholed into a
place because we're picking it
solely because the cost of living is
lower than
living somewhere else that makes sense
and so let's switch back to
the present time and about this pandemic
we have a quick question from our
viewers what are some other important
financial goals
as this pandemic continues
well i mean in terms of financial goals
during the pandemic
i think this has really illustrated the
importance of an emergency fund
you know there's there's different rules
of thumbs in terms of how much you
should have
in an emergency fund in case an
emergency hits and it depends on you
know whether
both spouses are working if only one
spouse is working but i think
a goal should most definitely be if you
have not established that emergency fund
always continue to work on that so that
you have your emergency fund
if something should occur like this
pandemic happens so it illustrates
how important an emergency fund is if
you don't have one that should be your
goal
another goal is paying off your debt but
it doesn't necessarily have to be
all debt because in order to reach
financial independence
you really have to have your sights on
investing you cannot just put your money
in a savings account and let it grow
over time because the return on that is
so
low it doesn't even keep up with the
cost of inflation
so the idea is that you really want to
get to a point where you can invest
but if you have debt in the form of very
high
credit cards you are exchanging you know
if you're not
paying off that debt then you're
investing but your return on your
investment
is likely going to be lower than those
very high interest rates on your credit
card
so another goal is to pay off those high
debts that you have so that you can
focus on getting to that space
where you can begin taking all your
extra money and investing it so there's
really
it depends on where you are yeah and i
want to add i want to add two
they're related but they're not in a
sequential order right so
one thing is insurance i think this
highlights the importance of having
good insurance in place and if it's
health insurance or life insurance
that's big hopefully you already have
that in place
the second thing is having another
source of income
a side hustle in place not a second job
a side hustle those are completely
different things
a side hustle is something that you can
start immediately maybe it's working for
you passively
in the background but it is something
that you are in control of you're not
working for
for someone else and the last thing is
the importance of having
an investment plan in place because when
this
pandemic hit people were very scared and
it's still very terrifying but if you
have an investment plan in place
you can focus on what's more important
in life like getting through this
pandemic
the health and welfare of your family
and your investment plan can be working
for you in the background
your investments are automated you don't
have to worry about that
so having this this this system in place
i think like christina said setting up
your emergency fund
the health insurance having your
ecosystem in place
so that during this pandemic you can
focus
on things that are most important and
getting through this healthy and safe
you know what i'm curious to know what
you guys think about
college loan debt you know there are
some rules of thought that are like
attack it as fast as you can um
but other schools of thought are more
like well take into consideration the
amount of debt that you owe
um and go from there what are you
thinking about that
well okay so we're we'll talk about it
through the sense that someone already
has
college debt right not whether or not
you should assume
debt while you're going through college
so if someone has debt i think
radita we're sort of in the middle of it
not that you have to pay it off
or not that you have to use that and
invest instead
you know it depends on your interest
rate so if you're thinking about
the historical returns in the market
on average it's been about an eight
percent return so if you have
and again it depends on your interest
rate with your student loans but if you
have a higher
rate on your student loan then you may
want to pay that off first
and focus on paying that off because you
know we always think when you pay off
debt that has a higher interest rate
you are guaranteed payments where in
that in the sense that you're
guaranteeing
a lower payment each time you you're
guaranteeing a rate of return
on that on that payment right like an
investment right yes and when you're
investing in the market for example
in the stock market or real estate
you're not you're not
you do not have a guaranteed return so
if you have a higher interest rate on
your student loan you may want to
consider paying that off first
now if you don't there's still a
mentality
associated with debt and sometimes
people have this mentality that
they want to get rid of debt they want
to be completely
debt free and if you have that mentality
and that's the mentality
that motivates you it may not be that
the numbers necessarily line up it may
mean
like if you do the calculations you may
be better off investing
if you look at it from a completely
statistical
analysis but mentally if
your mentality is that you must pay off
your loan because you don't want that
debt on you you don't want that hanging
over your head then maybe you should
also be focused on paying off your loan
now if none of these apply to you then
you have the other option
of just paying off the minimum
requirement for your student loan
and then investing the rest so we're
sort of in the middle on that one
yeah yeah it really depends on
everyone's situation
yeah but when it comes to investing
certain
investments you only have a window of
opportunity to make those investments
like a roth ira for example or getting
the match in your 401k
you have to you have to look at it in a
very comprehensive way
you don't want to throw all of your
money at your student loan and miss out
on these opportunities with your 401k
or being able to invest in a roth ira so
you
it all goes back to having a plan in
place
and if you're if you just have tunnel
vision you may miss out on all these
opportunities and we talked to people
all the time they were so focused on
their debt
that they missed out on these
opportunities to grow wealth
somewhere else you have to be able to do
more things than
than just one i get that okay thanks for
explaining that i
wanted to make sure i got that question
in well now i have a few rapid fire
questions
and the first one comes from our viewers
which is better owning or renting a home
oh that's a great question and i will
tell you there's no
strict answer for that i mean it's
really
we're we're very tied to numbers and
really understanding the numbers a lot
of people think
that owning property is the
is the ultimate way to go you should
always own property because if you're
renting
you're throwing your money towards
someone else to the landlord but that's
actually not always the case if you
start running the numbers and you look
at
the cost to rent versus the cost to own
and not just ownership but the
maintenance associated with
the mortgage or the home that you own
and you start to look at when you're
renting you have more flexibility in
terms of where you go
you may be more likely to get up and
move somewhere else for a job
opportunity
those are the things you have to keep in
mind so i would say there's
no clear answer as to whether it's
better to own or to rent
you have to look at your own unique
situation and where you live and really
run the analysis
i i will say one thing about renting if
you're going to rent
that means you're not going to be
building equity and most people that own
there
they're they're using it as almost as a
savings account so if you're renting
make sure that if you're saving money by
renting you're taking that savings and
investing it you're actually putting
that money to work
absolutely yes if you're if you're
renting it makes no sense to save the
money
and then the money that you save you go
out and you spend on a fancy new car or
something like that
but a depreciation depreciation
exactly next quick rapid fire question
to buy a credit or to get a credit card
or do not use a credit card
which one we use we use a credit card
and we think that if you can use a
credit card
responsibility and pay it off every
single month
in full then a credit card is a great
way to get
points um and and and yeah that's the
fastest answer
okay also and this is the last
quick rapid fire what was your craziest
side hustle
oh the craziest side hustle oh my
goodness um
whooper well okay okay so this is very
quick
so uh when uber first started it started
in the san francisco bay area and we
happened to be there when they
when it first started and at that time
there was uh there was something going
on where they would give you a sign up
bonus
and they'd also pay you just to have the
app on and at that time we lived in
in in the hills of oakland and because
uber wasn't that big
we signed up for it at that time we
turned on the app
we got a thousand dollars for signing up
we turned on the app and then we got 45
an hour and we never got a call from
uber we literally just
sat in our houses and collected the
money
from uber that was that was back then
this was a real
you know this was like the early days of
uber
okay and we do have another question
from our viewers how'd you get so good
at
content too you guys have several
different platforms that you're on
you also sell courses on your website oh
i saw one
for people who want to move to portugal
how'd you get for more content too
oh thanks that's a great question it's
the questions from people
right yeah we get a lot of i mean for us
our content always is generated really
from our journey and things that we've
experienced
and then we have a ton of comments from
people
that are suggesting new things like can
you talk about
how you invest in your 401k or can you
talk about this side hustle that you did
can you talk about real estate
so i mean it almost seems endless like
we we have so many ideas
but then we also get a lot of ideas just
from people
that watch our videos and are commenting
and suggesting videos that they want to
see
okay and the last question i have you
always talk about
what's your why for fi number one
tell us the importance of having a y for
financial independence
and what is your why for fi
okay so let me start backwards i'll say
my why
actually our why because we talk about
it throughout this and it ties to the
importance of having your wi-fi it's
our kids in each other being able to
spend
time with each other and not just the
the time where it's
getting up get ready get go to work do
this it's
by achieving financial independence by
retiring early
we have quality time with each other
and now we have quantity added to that
time so we get to spend
so much more time with each other and
with our kids
and that was our why for phi
and it's tied to the importance of
having a wife or five because
if you ever get to a point where you're
struggling or you're thinking this is
very hard to achieve
maybe you're not gonna get there if you
go back
to that why for five envisioning what
it's gonna be like
for you once you hit financial
independence or once you hit financial
independence and you retire
early that is the motivation and so
that's why i think it's so
important to really begin with your
wi-fi and
understanding why you're doing the
things that you're doing in order to
achieve
your ultimate goal it will help you stay
motivated
great we got the same brain
we have to add to that
i mean christina hit hit the nail on on
the head you know this
when we were on this on this journey it
like when people see our journey they
think oh it was all roses it was all
smooth
it wasn't smooth the stock market was
going up and down
there was chaos just like there is now
over the past previous
years so when we have this y for five
we love to visualize where we're gonna
be in the future
and now we're there and we continue to
do that so this
this y for five it's really the fuel for
our fire
i love that we had this going because
whenever we
had had a roadblock we said one day
we're gonna be there and we're here
okay well thank you so much guys for
joining us
and if you want to learn more about iman
and christina browning and our rich
journey you can check them out on their
social platforms at either
our rich journey or rich journey and
thank you very much for joining
your money story i'm renita young with
bloomberg quick take have a wonderful
friday
thanks ranita thank you guys